eltern irgendwann ist merkt man kann
halt nicht später sondern er hey was
geht ab und jetzt bekommen bei einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich euch
hierzu ich habe heute mal wieder juri
dabei ich weiß ja wohl noch kennt dann
haben wir ja schon ganz lange nicht mehr
gesehen
und zwar haben wir heute eine ganz
bestimmte challenge es ist wirklich eine
sehr sehr schwierige challenge die ich
mir ausgetüftelt hat das wieder
kreativarbeit genau und zwar geht es
heute darum welcher youtuber ist älter
also wir haben noch eine nette
assistentin hinter der kamera höchst mal
und diese in der tasse studentin hat
sich insgesamt keine ahnung so acht
verschiedene durchläufe ausgedacht wo
halt immer zwei youtuber daran
teilnehmen dann wird halt gefragt mal
als gutes beispiel
sag mal zwei youtuber große halt und der
prinz selbst älter als einfach zwei
youtuber werdenden raum geworfen und wir
müssen auf thailand sagen wer von den
beiden älter ist und der das wollten 123
nein das ist falsch wir machen einfach
mal kurz einem testdurchlauf dann hat
das jeder verstanden sagt einfach
irgendwelche schon ausgesucht habe ja
dann sagt 2
was also 123 suche sitzt man das so papa
ok hat denke ich jeder verstanden
ich würde sagen wir fangen an runde
nummer eins ok gefühlt
es wird nicht schwer also ich würde
sagen du zählst bis 3 und dann müssen
wir einen weiten rufen ob 1 oder 2 1 und
dann erwarte ich hab schon okay
26 ich sag 4 25 25 20 43 jahre geht noch
klar was machen wir wenn wir jetzt alles
gleich wichtig das glaube ich nicht da
wird es irgendwie
meinungsverschiedenheiten geben so
willkommen runde nummer zwei leute ganz
wichtig reicht ja auch immer in den
kommentaren mittel
ich will ganz viele kommentare sehen wo
drinsteht 32 27 ok 22 willkommen zur
nächsten runde gingen
vielleicht war gerechtfertigt dass ich
gefragt habe ob er alles richtig
java ab oder also ich weiß das glaube
ich habe ich will mir nicht 100
funktionen da man sich ja okay sagt man
einfach wo man sie haben aber bei denen
hätte ich jetzt gesagt dass wir zu am
schwersten war es echt unsicher aber ob
man jetzt irgendwo mal gelesen so ja ja
da gibt es ja auch irgendwie so ein fan
aus der sicht einer hebamme
[Gelächter]
das war jetzt echt nicht
ich hab' ich bin muss ich das einordnen
[Gelächter]
warte mal ja ich weiß nicht ich weiß ich
weiß es nicht aber ich bin heute morgen
sagen ja ich weiß ja wie alt die sind
aber dieses ding ist die sind beide 18
oder 19 schon keine ahnung okay sagt
einfach dass lukas liga mit 15 16 oder
sowas nenne ich wusste also ich wusste
dass sie beide 18 sind aber ich wusste
jetzt nicht wann die 18 geworden sind
schon jetzt setzt apple solltest du auch
sieben stück aus
da ist ich glaube die müssten okay ich
sage einfach ok 33 21 32
was die ist doch schon viel älter
ich hatte dann habe das nur gesagt weil
ich dachte wir auch so 24 oder so groß
weil die sich die haare
[Musik]
du kannst ja noch mehr aussuchen du
kannst du gleich noch zwei rausholen
warte mal kurzlich wir machen mal kurz
hier inzwischen viele leute schreibt ein
bisschen die kommentare
ob wir das ganze schwer findet oder ob
ihr das auch wissen würde
ich weiß das glaube ich was dann erst
wird julian khol herrlein bis 28 oder so
oder was weiß ich heute ist der war doch
schon 25 oder noch immer oder nicht
jetzt gesagt er wäre ich schon älter
theorie da war der honig / und ich ja
eine runde noch
kommen wir zum nächsten runde ich bitte
die frau quizmaster in die frage zu
stellen und zwar genau jetzt
das ist ein richtig richtig gute frage
weil katja ist glaube ich gar nicht mal
so viel älter als wir die s21 oder so
deswegen 36 liter kam halt nicht später
sondern eher leute leute wenn ihr meine
genialen reime weiterhin ertragen wollt
dann schaut auf jeden fall auf meinem
instagram 4 vorbei dann bei jedem neuen
foto steht auch ein genialer reihen
darunter
also ich filme noch mit einem punkt okay
wir kommen zur letzten runde das heißt
juli kann jetzt ausgleichen oder halt
mich
hast du selbst zurück das ist echt
schwer nicht ich würde ich habe glaube
ich meinen favoriten
ich weiß dann angesagt war ja immer
höher sagte was würdet ihr in die
kommentare schreiben
harris oder institute lieber wieder ist
der 25
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
dass das mit dem genialen video das auf
jeden fall noch nach oben abonniert auch
us- musiker komponiert auch julius
youtube kanal und wir noch ein paar
würde ich mal sagen
schauen wir mal aber ich bin die idee
aus und dadurch zur und wir sehen uns
dann demnächst wieder am sonntag gibt es
ein neues geniales video hat weil nach
berlin